bueno si estamos viendo una
intensificación
de los bombardeos
superior o similar a la que hubo al
menos en la primera del 14 pero yo creo
que de 2014 pero es importante tener en
cuenta que lo que parece que estamos
viendo es claramente a rusia generando
artificialmente un pretexto para una
intervención que ya tenía previamente
planeada y prevista y como puede afectar
este cese al fuego en las negociaciones
diplomáticas que se están llevando hasta
el momento
bueno negociaciones diplomáticas como
tal no ha habido tal es lo que ha habido
de resistencia ante el ultimátum y el
chantaje que planteaba rusia y ahora
rusia como sus demandas como su chantaje
no ha sido satisfecho lo que claramente
está tiene en fin a todo apunta que va a
hacer es incrementar la tensión militar
y lanzar algún tipo de ataque no pero
esto es lo que estamos viendo no está
subiendo la tensión y generando
artificialmente un pretexto que legitime
una una intervención militar
entonces se podría decir que estos
bombardeos responden más a una muestra
de fuerza por ambos bandos o como usted
dice por parte de rusia o se podría
estar llegando a un enfrentamiento
directo en el este de ucrania
a ver es que un cráneo no tiene ningún
interés en esto porque pensemos que
ucrania no tendría ningún sentido que
estuviera esperando durante dos meses y
medio a que rusia termine de desplegar
todo su ejército en todas las fronteras
de ucrania incluyendo como vamos a ver
este fin de semana toda su flota y
submarinos en el mar negro y marc gasol
para llevar a cabo maniobras nucleares y
una vez que rusia desplegado todo su
ejército la mayor fuerza o la mayor masa
de fuerza militar que se ha visto en
europa desde la segunda guerra mundial
entonces es cuando ucrania decide lanzar
unos ataques contra la población civil
que obligan a rusia a responder el
digamos el montaje o el pretexto de
rusia es tan evidente que responde a una
operación planeada que bueno este es el
contexto en el que estamos no porque no
tendría ningún sentido por parte de
ucrania que está insistiendo en que
ellos no tienen ninguna intención de
tratar de recuperar por la vía militar y
las dos porciones de territorio de
bombas que controla rusia y mucho menos
en el momento en el que rusia desplegado
a todo su ejército alrededor de ucrania